hi there steve kaufman here today
i want to talk about
role playing in the classroom
um
drills
and getting to
speaking in the language
and i'm doing this because i am now
at the stage where i want to speak in
arabic i'm doing a lot of listening a
lot of reading i've got a lot of words
and phrases in my mind now i sometimes
say them to myself i want to start using
them with people i want to stumble i
want to struggle i want to get some
feedback i know that that i need to do
that now i'm over 4 000 known words at
link
granted in arabic you get a lot of
freebie
words because of the way they attach the
and
what to
different words
but i think i'm just about there i could
wait a bit longer but i'm close
and since we are
in the process of revamping our whole
tutorial
system
at link i want to wait until we have
that
actually functioning which isn't very
far away and then i'm going to invite
arabic speak native speakers of arabic
to come on and teach arabic and i will
be using their
uh services to a great extent but then
it got me to think about certain my
conference that i attended in portland
where they have these stories where they
engage the class and all the different
ways in which in a classroom teachers
have to try to engage the class in some
way
and there are different techniques used
one of these is role playing where
two students pretend to be i don't know
at the grocery store or something and
they pretend that they are two people
acting out some scenario
in the language they're learning
uh
drills for example is another way that
teachers like to elicit some response
from from the learner uh pimsleur does
this where they you you are prompted to
say something and to answer
uh i've been listening to the defense
language institute arabic material
and there again there are a bunch of
drills where they give often quite
complicated instructions on what you're
supposed to do
uh change the predicate into something
or hold and i can never understand half
have it i shouldn't say never but a lot
of times it's quite confusing as what
they as to what they want you to do
until you start to hear a few examples
but i never do it i just listen i just
listen and in all of their drills i just
listen to the pattern and i find that
listening to the pattern is much more
powerful than me interjecting
my effort to remember what was in the
sentence and to try to do whatever it is
they ask you to do to i find that a
burden
and and something that's unpleasant to
do in all of the language books that i
use
whenever there are drills or questions i
never do them i may read
the
various sentences which very often you
know highlight a particular pattern or i
might go to the answers and read all of
the answers which highlight a particular
pattern so it's this exposure to a
pattern that i find useful whereas doing
the drills i don't find useful by the
same token the role playing is not
something that i would willingly
participate in because it's not natural
i believe that
listening to interesting stories or even
listening to you know a concentration
concentrated exposure to certain
patterns is gradually increasing the
ability improving the ability of the
brain
to sift through and sort through and
organize this language that ultimately
just as i prefer my listening and
reading to be
on subjects of interest to me
you know i also prefer
my speaking to be on subjects of
interest to me
so that's why i wait until i at least
have some words in the language and some
comprehension
so that now
i can start speaking to someone and i
would rather speak
on a subject of interest rather than
pretending that i am a clerk in a store
or uh you know work at the post office
or whatever it might be
i will ask the person where do you live
he lives in
i don't know a syrian refugee in turkey
how is life in turkey are there many
refugees there from syria what's going
to happen in syria those are the kinds
of discussions that i will have in
arabic and those will be meaningful uh
discussions and so that is an
opportunity for me to practice output to
find out what i'm missing to go back to
my input to work on words and phrases
for the next encounter but the next
encounter with my tutor will again be a
real encounter speaking it won't be a
drill it won't be role playing it won't
be any of these things it'll be
something meaningful to me
so
that's why personally
uh being prompted to say something being
prompted to perform a role
uh
being prompted to respond to drills all
of this is something that i
resist now maybe that's just a personal
preference in fact it's certainly a
personal preference other people you
know have different approaches but i
just wanted to explain
the approach that i take and
let you know that i'm looking forward to
starting to speak in arabic but i don't
want to do it until we have our new
speaking platform at link uh and then
you'll be able to follow my my progress
uh i'm even thinking of
of uh maybe tracking say if i speak
every day
then over a period of a week or so or
two
just tracking my progress
at least for my own purpose so i'll save
a minute of each discussion
and i'll then have at least for my own
purposes a record of my progress as i
start to activate
my arabic learning
okay thank you for listening
bye for now
[Music]
you